sour third plenary speaker is go ping
Frank grouping Frank is the boy is
professor of neuroscience in brain and
cognitive sciences and in the McGovern
Institute and groupings appointment and
recruitment I regarded the coup for for
for MIT and for bcs grouping started his
lab here last June and we have been
thrilled by already the impact that
grouping has had on our community so
goofy Thank You MacGregor um I'm very
happy to be here to give you an overview
of the current status of psychiatric
research and so you probably all know
they're the mental illness and
psychiatric disorders are a very bigger
problem so they are estimated about 400
you know for half a billing of people
around the world has second mental
illnesses and nearly a million people
every year commit suicide and they are
you this is one of the leading as a
group is the one of the leading causes
of disability lived with life and this
is probably most surprising most
astonishing fact is waiting for fat
waiting for family has at least one
member has mental illness and so the
effect not only the patient but also the
family members because most of the care
are in many other cases are you know
care to by family members so there's a
huge burden in the Indus asiah tea so as
a group neuropsychiatric disorders are
the largest basically and cost burdens
of disease worldwide for disability last
days of you know there's basically lived
with the disability so this is a huge
problem despite is a huge problem and
have been recognized for year for
decades but there's not many option of
treatment so this is a slides and a
discon- director of psychical research
and give
recently and I used actually a few of
his slides of these data so basically in
the past you know sixty years they've
just significant dramatic increase in
the for example and drag is that with no
mechanism to treating heart disease but
it almost no change on for dragons for
treating you know depressing and
suffering so the problem is a big are
even bigger than before but the
treatment options are very few and very
you effective so why why it's not like
pharmaceutical company are not
interested in deriving these are
considered commercially are very
profitable you know hug it the problem
is that the one of the biggest reason
that the main reason actually failed all
buildings of buildings a billion dollars
have been spent by pharmacy company and
a research institute the fail but failed
to develop a joke the main reason is
that we actually don't know the magnet
what causes disorders and what are the
underlying pathology of these disorders
so there are many many example you can
say you know pharmacy grant companies
spend billions of dollars to try to
develop all kind of drugs by the end
most of them are fail the reason is you
know it's just a guess you know a guess
then there's no understanding of disease
there's no good animal models so what do
you do you use in a lab stat test tube
or at the most of your culture cell a
cell then say okay what do you do
effective let's start a clinical child
and so it's basically a black box let's
see spanner you know 20 to 200 million
dollars to see where the communicator
have effect or not so most of them you
can get you you know other well you know
very smart and pharmacy or company
scientist and the CEO they are super
smart but it's just a guess all right so
most of them fails just as early we show
that you most our clinical trial for
ultimate disease are failed so so the
this tell you the most important scene
for develop treatment for any of the
disorders especially for brain disorders
is to understand the underlying
pathology of a new and in the line
neurobiology and
neuropathology of these disorders so how
to have the wave how are we going to
figure out this you know in the line
pathology and the cost so there are four
psychiatric disorder very very strong
evidence there is a genetic factors
contribute the two to these disorders
this is the chart just show you that in
general population for this is just for
bipolar and schizophrenia is a branded
one to two percent of incidence but in
the family members parents siblings of
children of any of the family if has
disorder then the chance of their
siblings or parents are much much higher
incidence so it means there's a very
significant tribution from genetic
factors so and previously you know ten
years ago before you know ten years ago
is almost impossible to think about it
how we're going to figure out all these
differences because you genome
everyone's sitting here and there are
many many differences that they are you
know thousands are millions of
differences how do we going to figure
out so but now there are ways you can do
rights because the advance of Technology
so so the basically based on that the
key sing to the future of psychic
research in developing last probably
mostly in last less than ten years seven
or eight years is on the two front winch
is genetics and genomics to figure out
the genetically contributors or causes
or risk factors that can lead to
psychiatric disorders then use that
information to help us to understand if
you have that risk factor I have that
mutation whatever what happens to the to
the neurobiology or neural circuits and
pathways in the in the patient brain
that are we whether we can potentially
correct so so the frontiers are
basically we're talking about with
genetic genomics and your circular
pathways and so for the genetics
basically the new genomic technologies
are driving the genetics so now we can
let the technology develop study with
you know whole genome human genome
sequencing and the prediction at that
time when it study will take you know 20
years to sequence a one human genome but
now it you know you can do it in
probably weeks and to solve that so so
this
dramatic advanced technology which we
have a huge advantage here at MIT in
collaboration with the Broad Institute
is that and that give us a you know the
the most current up-to-date and
knowledge on the other genetic causes
and genetic factors involved in
psychiatric disorders so we basically
now with the technology if there's
enough funding and you can basically
identify all kind of variations between
humans and specific patients and the
specific group of disorders so that give
us a very strong and foundation to start
to understand what is going on with the
neurobiology of this this disorders so
in so so with the genetic basis then it
give us a tool basically can use animal
models our model system to say if we
have a mutation in this patient we
identified the other thing you know
contributed to this schizophrenia
obsessive-compulsive disorder autism or
bipolar disorder and we can use model
system to try to figure out what is you
know what went wrong with in this brain
and that the hope is that by
understanding the neural circuit defect
and pathways then it will help us to
understand what figure out a way to
treat them to correct this problem so
I'm going to use an example in my lab
which we have been using a mice as a
model there many other model system can
be used to study and we will have a
panel to discuss this about these
different models and will you example a
simple example in my lab to connect it
from genetics human genetics to animal
models from behavior to understand
neural circuits to illustrate how we can
go on to understand these these most
debilitating and complex disorders in
the brain so one of the main area and in
the last few years have emerged in that
the many of the defect are concentrated
are in one places basically is that the
place with the neurons and neuron
neurons communicate because if we think
about whatever we do whatever behavior
our motion all depend on neural circuit
activity and we have billions of neurons
in the brain and they don't randomly
connect they have very precise
connections and then they also have very
precise and a millisecond scale very
precise communications right if you do
you know one particular thing they are a
group of neural activated and precisely
this nuance any signal to activate
different specific muscles so you can
raise your left left hand on right hand
and you can think about all other your
speech yeah you're hearing your you know
behavior angry or emotion everything is
controlled basically related to neural
circuitry activity so these all depends
on neurons communicate hundreds of
thousands are many of them so most of
the neutron communicate through a very
small apparatus and when a couple Mike
micron-sized called synapses so because
the neuronal communication is critical
to our brain function you can imagine
this is the set basically a hot spot for
disorders and so neurons these are just
drawings of how neurons make connections
so this is basically the receiving
neuron there are many other neurons
sending you send their axons to make a
connections and these as the site called
synapses they send signals chemical
signals through this sort of a circles
then released and then the receptor on
the other side will receive a signal
turning to different electrical signals
and the chemical signals leading to gene
not only the response electrical
response was also gene transcription
changes that you heard from Lee waste
talked about them in the Alzheimer
disease brain so in this little teeny
tiny space which is this is joining our
one of the synapse which is at a post
and website just this little receiving
side actually there this is about a
couple of microns at a very chip which
is you know and about 100 to 200
nanometer size they are up to a silent
type of proteins cluster there to make
sure our brain function properly so it
says two things right one is that the
brain really this synapse also very
small does a lot of things right there
are many different ways to modulated
regulate the function on the other hand
if you have so many things needed to
regular function you also the trouble
spot like many of these genes of
immunity Singh can cause the problem
will synapse and may cause a lot of
problems for cycles we decided and and
the neurological disorders so so in my
lab like many other lab so we have many
many labs in Allenwood are very
interested how this synapse assembled
how they function regulated and what do
we go around if some genes are mutated
in and what do we go down with the
synaptic function where we go wrong with
their behavior in the whole animal so we
are focusing I give you an example and
we're focusing a give you example on
this protein so this this complex will
call scaffolding complex they consist of
several group of proteins that are
linking to each other that they form a
scaffold so now when you have scaffold
then you can bring other proteins into
the into the synapse and assemble a
large macro molecular structure that
will help to function at the synapse and
also modulate synaptic function because
our synapse our brain is not only it's
it's not a function you know properly
but also it's very dynamic right it's
not like a static when we make a wire
connection in the computer it'll never
change this is change it's constantly
changing constantly am equipping learn
things we can eliminate assist with
forget things all these are very dynamic
process all these processes most of the
happens at the synapse so so so this
complex is very important for assembly
every synapse but also bring all the
signaling proteins into this synapse to
modulus and have function which means
that if we figure out what's going wrong
here we can also find a way to modulate
this this self so maybe we can find a
ways to correct the problem in
psychiatric disorders so one of the
protein i will show you how this rubble
this protein called a cpap one of the
family members can lead to abnormal
behavior and how we can correct this
problem so there are four families and
one of them called a setup episode is
highly expressive in one area called
striatum you heard there from Miriam
talk about Australia them which is
control almost all movements and also
behavior and you
is that bring area and data control the
movement and the variety of behaviors
especially related to repetitive
compulsive behaviors and you know
obsessive-compulsive disorder in autism
and also you Tourette's syndrome and
check tell a minute all this is with
repetitive compulsive behaviors in
psychiatric disorders so when we mutated
is this in mice what you can see is that
these mice have repetitive compulsive
behavior this is a mutant of my mouth we
took it out put on the kg top and
usually you somehow maybe have expect
you take a mouse outer cage the first
instinct is ego is wrong away from you
right your instinct is to try to catch
it but this mouse is the mutant mouse
you put on the package atop it gets to
stay there it stays it and it seems the
grooming compulsively grooming itself is
more important than the basically
mystical run away so you can actually
videotape videotape it so this type of
next slide that we show you the very you
know graphic dramatic so basically this
constant grooming and lead it to a cross
bloody facial region so the basic groom
is your hair and skin off they'll remind
us that the obsessive-compulsive
disorder so some patients they were
washes at hand 500 times day they are
bleeding this still can I can do they
still want to watch at the hand so so
this is so when you videotape and to
look at what do they do during 24 hour
period right the normal mice they spend
the less than ten percent of total their
daily time grooming that my cell like
humid the cleaner skiing's they clean
themselves we also can you probably
don't spend temps and our data time to
cook any ourselves so myself better than
that way but at the other hand right so
this mutant mice this basically spend a
third of day grooming themselves so they
cannot shake of this grooming you know
compulsively imperative like a grooming
so they'll lead us to think this may be
a model that the based on the expression
the stratum of striatum which has been
used clinical studies in OCD patient has
been strongly implicated in OCD
obsessive-compulsive disorder any autism
so so we decided to look at whether
these mice also
show the symptoms of cefiro types
similar to other aspects that OCD OC
these anxieties spectrum they saw the
most of patient has a very dramatic
increase anxiety and we use you in mice
it's very actually they're very standard
ways to test their anxiety-like behavior
and we show that these mice also have
dramatically increased anxiety which
which is very similar to what a you know
an OCD patient experience and then there
are no specific treatment for OCD there
are actually no specific treatment for
any psych major psychiatric disorders
because we still don't know what I call
them or what's the underlying pathology
but they are the most frequent user drug
which are partially effective is a
prozac type of drugs actually in n so we
tested the mice and we can see that
these mice are very effective in in this
impatient these are only partially
effective your about fifty percent
patients so so as a 50-percent basically
they have no treatment and the fifty
percent which are about fifty percent
which are affected only partially factor
usually there is no cure for them but
these mice also when we treat them
fluxing projects they are also partially
effective you can choose some of the
symptoms need advice so this kind of
test led us to believe that maybe these
mice can be used as a model to figure
out what is going wrong what is going on
in the brain of this mouse actually lead
them to groom themselves that groom the
hand the skin off they'll still keep
doing this a symptom which is resembling
some of you d like a behavior so one of
the kissing is that there are many
studies have shown suggested that the
communication between caught our cortex
to the striatum back then to the
thalamus and back to the cause this loop
neural circuits is involved but there's
no direct evidence that defect here
actually can call those it because you
cannot just go and you know doing any of
these lesions are damaged Lee impatient
to test this but in animal models you
can actually not only you can test this
but you can also try to can we fix this
by the expression like you know these
genes into this area so so the first
thing we did is to use electrical
recording to
show that indeed there is a dramatic
defect in communication between these
cortical cells to the neurons with the
striatal neurons and and then we can say
this is muting demise they are lacking
protein they have synaptic defect neuron
your community fair in the stratum can
we can we prove that the defect in this
area called striatum is the key and can
we so the way we can do is advise it you
can selectively to express this gene
only in this area to correct the problem
not none everywhere else is still be has
a mutation but only in these neurons you
expressed you can you correct the
problem the answer is yes so when we put
this a control virus into this area and
these mice you have leading the grooming
still like I call them crazy device and
so they still grooming them like the
gloomy their hair and skin off but in
this in Unum eyes the mutant mice if you
put it gene back only in the striatum in
that Spring area and it does not do it
anymore so these mice actually you
basically cure this this problem so they
give the direct evidence that a defect
in this bring area striatum that snapped
the synaptic defect which means an Iran
Iran commish communication problem a
defect is the cognitive to this problem
now you have a direct evidence that that
is that the problem now that we get us
excited maybe we can find a way to treat
you know better way to treat a patient
the problem is my cell not humans right
you may be there are many studies you
might may be affected by the anatomy may
not be affecting human so how do we know
this gene this type of mutation actually
control contributor to Hume appeal so
now with the genetical as I mentioned
earlier as a key and also an aspect as
an advance to advance our understanding
of psychiatry disorder is we cannot go
back use the use the sequence technology
to sequence this geno CD patient we
actually do that and we found that they
are actually found a quite a few mutate
and we caught a variance basically a
genetic differences between the OCD
patients and the normal normal people so
these
seeing these we call the variance
genetic material differences between
between the two groups and the so with
the mice give you the opportunity but
what we don't know is whether these are
causative to the patient right you
cannot go to create this in humans but
you can go to curtis's in mice so so
what we did is we can create this
ability executive mutation we're finding
a human and create this mutation in yo
mouth gene because mouth aging and the
human gene in this gene in most of us
genes are almost identical at the
protein levels so we show that this
mutation we found in humans Oh see the
actual complete loss of function so
which is suggested that there a single
nucleotide one nucleotide change right
leader that me their leader to one amino
acid change actually completely lost
basically leader to the complete loss of
function its protein so now where we
actually made a mouse instead of mutated
hoji just to put this mutation a single
mutation funny OCD patient into a mouse
and we're waiting for my if the mouse
actually shows a very similar phenotype
of OCD like a phenotype then it tells us
that this meeting we found a human
patient probably will contribute it to
the OCD in their patient it's probably
strong ever you know one stronger
everything you can ever get to prove
that a mutated genetic variation you
found in a human patient accurate can be
contributed to the to the problems in
the patient the most exciting is that if
we think that circuitry defect is the
key then there are many implications the
first of all the more to Muslim
important package is our first if if the
synaptic defect neuron your
communication in this area is key then
we can predict many of the genes as I
said about a sound type of proteins
involved in assembly function and the
plasticity of the synapse then many
other genes which are important for the
development of function of the synapse
in australia there may be very also very
important and they may also their
mutation may also contribute cause the
same problem so then that lead us to
have a collaboration with actually
brawling Stute and
Center for psychiatric disorder broadens
to sequence out you know six hundred
genes which are all highly expressing
this area and a secret sauce in the
patient can we find a custom of these
mutations in this gene compared to other
genes which are not expressed here so
that give us a very strong the world if
it's true it will give us a very strong
evidence that genes involved in this new
york circuit is critical to the
pathology of the patio compulsive
behavior then the second prediction is
that if this is the case then you may be
able to find treatment by just the
modulated the circuitry function it
doesn't matter what Eugene because right
now if there are three hundred genes
involved in OCD there's nowhere we can
go individually treated Emma correctly
because gene therapy is still years away
and is not a trivial right now but if
it's a circuitry defect if they cause a
similar neural circuit defect then the
only thing needed to do use the
technology marin has mentioned that she
can figure out that we what are the
difference between the gene expression
and and the signaling pathways between
the patient and you know this mouse
model and the other normal mouse then
you will have a pathway actually they
already she already did this work
actually in this pathway and the
published several papers and very nice
papers and you basically can use the
current knowledge once you figure out
the circuit if I use the current
knowledge actually go on to directly
modulated function activity of the
neural circuitry and use a small
chemical to correct this problem so this
give us a hope that by combined genetics
and neural structure and studies use
animal model as the step stone maybe
soon what we have I hope as soon and as
soon as a not a days a month yeah and at
least a few years away that it will have
a much better approach a strategy to
treat it as a terrible psychiatry result
this is just example OCD a similar
experiment has been going on in my lab
before autism and a bipolar disorders
all these we hope you combined with many
other advances in the field that it
eventually will give us a hope that will
have a much specific and much more
effective treatment for psychiatric
disorders and so so that's this is any
slide will show maybe we have a circus
specific treatment basically
what is the second you saw this thank
you in fact for a couple of questions
before we break out
just changing one
technically similar but conceptually
it's a difference so a knockout means we
completely eliminated the gene function
and in most of the mutations or variants
we found humans they're usually the art
deletions like this copy number
variations are deletions which are not
as common as the point of mutation
single so the new Kings means you can
knock in any kind of mutation you
finally human into the locus of
messaging that mimic identical miracle
the mutagen funding in humans yeah you
just change your singlet if it's a
single amino acid nuclei change we just
replace that nucleotide a single
nucleotide anywhere in the genome
basically in a mouse you can do that now